Yeah, I hear that.
I'm over 40. I'm pushing 50.
Bring it back off. Negative not happening.
In fact, I'm stepping up. Um,
trading harder, eating cleaner. [inaudible] I'm training,
learning and reading and studying more now than I ever have in my whole life.
Do I get dinged up? Of course I did.
[inaudible] factor, no factor. Deal with them.
[inaudible] I hear, I hear the clock ticking.
Best buy here.
[inaudible] waits for no man.
You young guns out there.
18 years old, 20 years old, 24 years old. Listen,
life goes by
[inaudible] waste those years and don't waste them live.
I know you're going to live to be 30 much less than 40,
but you are and you will
in the earlier you get in the game, the better life you're going to have.
Wealthy you stronger, smarter, better
than 80.
If you put old man like me and you haven't gotten on track yet,
get on track. Get on it. Now here's the deal.
No complacency, no complacency,
no backing off.
No slack whatsoever. Fight.
Fight that ticking clock with every feet. God.
So the end of a hard day.
Put your head down
satisfied.